it's day 11 10:20 p.m. we've both had
pretty much a bla day hey live worthy
day I got to work and I got an email
from you were looking for an apartment
but someone took my friend's apartment
I call it my friend's apartment because
it was like mine two of the apartments
on friends how wonderful they are some
[ __ ] took it from us they go I don't
even know if they were girls
men can be [ __ ] so I came home and I
watered Chinese food and before I even
ate my food I read my fortune today your
mouth might be moving but no one is
listening on your mind I would love to
hear yours love or money , or neither
question mark no money more problems you
know all the words to that song yeah me
my cousin I don't know if you know this
but I don't know much about rap the dog
is shaking it's not a seizure because my
dog has seizures and all they do is go
mmm
I've learned a lot in the past six years
of being a dog owner you have to set the
discipline level right away or the dog
will be a pain in the ass I'm
passive-aggressive I know your dog would
be a piece of [ __ ] my dog would be any
kind of a [ __ ] my dog would be a cat
get it it's fine because my mouth was
moving but you guys weren't listening to
that anyway when I was younger fortunes
are really good like you have lots of
ice cream tonight yeah yeah you do that
your parents love you hi cliff the don't
want to see the dog ones old like I'm
too digital faces still shake it a
little bit he's just nervous to be on
camera go sleep now we're done guy I
just can't speak English it's pretty
much the moral this blog